[Music]
cloud computing has helped many
industries innovate to new heights and
healthcare is no exception
in previous videos in this series we
looked at how the cloud healthcare api
can help you store and access healthcare
data in google cloud
in this episode we'll explore how the
cloud healthcare api can be used to
store retrieve and analyze medical
imaging data
[Music]
[Applause]
there are several key challenges that
healthcare professionals face when
dealing with medical imaging
first you need to ensure hippa
compliance in clinical workflows to
ensure patient privacy
second researchers often have to learn
about new technologies which can be
confusing and expensive
and third it can be difficult to
leverage this data to gain important
insights using big data and machine
learning
luckily the cloud healthcare api
addresses these challenges with one of
its endpoints and comes packed with
other helpful features for medical
imaging analysis it supports digital
imaging and communications in medicine
also known as dicom an international
standard file format used for storing
and transmitting medical images across
technologies
this could include x-rays mris
ultrasounds and more
it can also help you save money by
enhancing or even removing the need for
specific on-premise software that
requires expensive licensing fees
and it makes it easy to scale customer
architectures while maintaining low
latency and high performance
the cloud healthcare api also helps you
leverage the power of machine learning
by integrating well with vertex ai
google cloud's unified ai platform
and finally it connects easily with open
source tools like the open health
imaging foundation viewer also known as
the ohip viewer which lets you view
medical images for the purpose of
analysis
this is because the cloud healthcare api
exposes the dicom store through a dicom
web interface
users who might be interested in using
the cloud healthcare api for imaging
include radiologists who may want to
view images
researchers and data scientists who may
want to use images for diagnostics
and i.t decision makers and clinical
organizations who are looking to reduce
costs and improve storage scale and
elasticity
let's take a look at an example of how
the cloud healthcare api can be used to
build a spine detection machine learning
model using a small set of dicom ct
images
first images are ingested into a dicom
store
a data store is simply a place to store
a certain type of healthcare data so a
dicom store is a place to store dicom
medical images
next we can view the images from the
dicom store using ohif an open source
medical imaging viewing tool that
integrates directly with the google
cloud healthcare api
images can then be parsed into metadata
and stream to bigquery for further
analysis
bigquery is google cloud's large-scale
data warehouse that's great for storing
analyzing and visualizing large data
sets
with metadata ingested into bigquery it
becomes much easier to search across a
large amount of image metadata that
wouldn't be readily searchable in other
systems for example we could search for
the most recent 20 images of lung cancer
diagnosis
once our bigquery search is done we can
use the corresponding dicom web path to
find the specific image for further
analysis
the next step is to use filtered export
to export specific image instances to
cloud storage which is used to store
file objects in the cloud
filtered export is useful because you
may want to export specific images from
a larger data set to cloud storage and
convert them from dicom to png or jpeg
for further analysis
once the images are in cloud storage we
can then start training our machine
learning model using these images as our
test data set
first we can import the images into
vertex ai as an object detection data
set
vertex ai is google cloud's unified
machine learning platform that makes it
easy to build and train machine learning
models on google cloud
then we can label these test images
directly in vertex ai using the cloud
console
here's where we can label images that
have a spine in them
once our test dataset is ready we can
start to train our prediction model we
can use automl which actually does most
of the work for us
all we have to do is provide a labeled
training data set and google cloud
automatically builds us a machine
learning model that leverages its
powerful computing resources
no prior knowledge of machine learning
is required
once automl finishes building the ml
model will get an online prediction
endpoint that can be used to predict
whether or not new images have spines in
them
the final step is to use the ohip viewer
to view images from the healthcare api
dicom store and use the online
prediction endpoint to give us our ml
predictions
here we have our image being shown in
the ohip viewer
under predictions we can click find
spine to call the online prediction
endpoint hosted on vertex ai
and since a spine is detected it is
outlined with a box directly in the
image viewer itself
we can also take a look at the
javascript console to see what's going
on behind the scenes when we hit find
spine
there are just two api calls the first
api call is a render request to the
cloud healthcare api which we use to get
a rendered view of the image
the second api call is to an online
prediction endpoint hosted on vertex ai
this is what we use to predict whether
or not there's a spine in the image
the response we get back includes
confidence scores as well as bounding
box information for the spine detected
in the end ohif renders the image as
well as the bounding box on top of the
image
as you can see the cloud healthcare api
provides a powerful platform to help you
analyze medical imaging data
an important feature is that it
integrates well with google cloud
products like bigquery cloud storage and
vertex ai giving you new ways to gain
invaluable insights about medical
imaging data while complying with hipaa
and other government regulations
to learn more visit cloud.google.com
healthcare
to get started you'll need to have a
google cloud project if you don't have
one we've included a link to a trial
account with free credits in this
video's description along with other
helpful resources
and friends if you found this episode
helpful please subscribe to the channel
to get notifications of more health care
episodes cheers
[Music]
[Music]